- hello powers start get it rocket it's
the a3 pocket is your boy Ethan Klein
the Entertainer I'm here to entertain
it's my calling and life to sit here
before you and to explain things in a
way that's both funny and easy to
understand with me as my coat is that
not my calling in life why do you make
that face you know you wear it for you
to say that about yourself no what did
have that calling in life what you say
it about me I don't know okay
well somebody's got to say it and if
it's not you then it's gonna be me it's
my call in the streets the streets are
saying it that's how you'd say it
because then you don't look like a dick
the streets are saying it thank you to
Brook linen and kaptara for sponsoring
this action-packed episode of the HP
podcast
let's just get right into it as you guys
know we had a blockbuster episode last
week with Trisha Paytas that the streets
are talking about and they are we had a
what were you thought international
streets you know I had a couple messages
from people in Israel mmm that I've
never spoken to justify I went to school
it would they say I didn't really read
the full message I just thought a little
short you've changed you're such a big
shot down well I haven't spoken to this
person did you not want them to see that
it was much yeah yeah do you think
they're watching right now I don't know
do I know who they are do I know this no
okay no you have no idea
[ __ ] them well they said that it was a
great episode well that's very kind of
them I also got some kudos Trisha you
know she's just she's such an
entertaining person she's a little wild
a little crazy I liked when she insisted
that we were Hasidic Jews but they had
it it spawned a lot of memes on our
subreddit so I wanted to go over some of
the memes and guys please keep the h3
memes coming because it's so much fun
and I want to keep going over these
every week because you guys are
producing so here we go she said oh this
is a very popular meme format yeah and
nowadays congratulations thank you I
used to swallow a goldfish as a kid and
then you say huh not much to it really
but there you have it when you when you
invite Trisha to squash the beef but she
instead hits on your husband now how did
you feel about her hitting on me because
she did do that not cool I was watching
one of these tea spill channels that was
doing like a summary of the podcast and
they said that it was a long theorized
thesis that she was into me even before
she said that people thought that she
was into me according to the team people
that felt that part felt to me a little
bit like she was just trying to so
you're taking this away from me that
someone would be attracted to me other
than you no but I wouldn't give her I
don't think it was that planned out
mm-hmm
so do you but do you think that she
wants me or no I think she has like ten
different Tricia's inside and one of
them probably one of them wants me yeah
that's actually a fair explanation I was
trying to get like defensive that you
would that you would dare think that
another girl wouldn't want me but that
explanation I can't even argue with yeah
well she said I was a ten I was like no
one ever the highest rating I've ever
got was like a six on my best day when I
was doing water polo mm-hm so I got like
a six and I was like oh girl what are
you doing later now I'm probably yet
like I'm probably like a three these
days with the fat would the choppiness
going on I saw you're not at 3 with the
fatness if I get my [ __ ] together I
think I can max out it at 6 you could
max out higher what do you think I max
at 8 really yeah that's sweet agent
really I the thing is if I got my [ __ ]
together
and I was single this hypothetical
doesn't it falls apart because I'm only
having money because of my partnership
with you but let's just say in a
parallel universe that I was successful
okay and I had my [ __ ] together
physically yeah I could maybe see myself
being at eight at highest but I feel
like the success factor definitely gives
a lot of extra points oh yeah you know I
wasn't including this excel if you were
single right now without losing money
hey losing weight without losing weight
same successful you could have probably
a different girl every weekend because
it's done raising are you a horse dad no
not having your the weekend do you think
for example I could pull like a
supermodel yes thank you well I've
already got a supermodel already pulled
one so that's exciting but it's weird
well the success success affection yeah
come on it's weird
well there's so there's a wealth factor
and then on top of that there's like a
Fame factor yeah so I'm not super high
on the Fame totem pole but like if I
figure if I was a little girl people
start seeing like Oh Ethan let me get a
picture then all of a sudden these girls
are like is it just me or is it uh is
there a waterfall of my pants why is it
just me yeah but once they see my penis
then I go back down to a3 you know you
know these little hooks you put in the
wall to like hang pictures they're like
tiny little hook that you drill into the
wall and then you like hang stuff on it
okay that's what my penis looks like
it's like a little crescent moon how
would you know okay fair enough
anyway let's go these memes Trisha when
she said she's a lesbian and also a game
for him
that was a actually a quote that I liked
a lot I said can you be both a lesbian
any gay man she's like yes I mean I'm
having a hard time following the logic
there but Trisha Paytas I'm born a girl
that defines herself as a gay guy
doesn't dress like a guy and doesn't
take any gender hormones that [ __ ] guys
any normal human being
well that sounds like a being straight
with extra steps that's a good point and
the podcast with Trisha at 9:29 we got
timestamps and a meme Trisha says that
Ethan is a chubby guy so we can make fun
of a chubby guy I'm a chubby girl and I
can make fun Trevor girls this this is
minutes after she claims she was a trans
male you know that's a really good point
I saw people mentioning that we fail to
fail to pick up on she kept saying I
cannot I cannot make fun of fat girls
because I'm a guy but then she was
saying you can't make fun of me cuz
she's a fat girl but she's a fat guy if
she's fat
it's like it's just the logic is so
there was no logic to anything oh this
was a great I love the damn with chips
meme dan is the pizza here and just
stand with chips in the back well you
know I was trying to just move it along
but it's fine I mean it the episode was
great every minute was great Dan are you
[ __ ] with me where's the pizza Dan do
how do you feel about the chips meme I
enjoy it yeah it's good yeah what was
that originally from you I was eating
chips and you got mad at me well we we
were all heated up I think yelling at
you all right everything like what's
then what do you think a lot of chips
here in all kinds of flavors he doubled
down on the chip honestly ILA's high
when Tricia was flirting with Ethan no I
don't frankly get that I understand so
it starred David but I didn't get that
what I mean you know why did your I get
a start David well I think it's it's
that it's changing colors because she's
going like super saiyan she's going
sicko mode she's going sick of motive
our Pete and her eye is the Star of
David
yeah I mean that's just that's what
happens when Jews get angry right yeah
oh yeah it must be feeling when that
beak off has seeds had secret Jewish
powers so what the Hassid super secret
Jewish power be they'll spray away their
sweat I was thinking that they can like
clean their body without showering
that'd be epic they have like their her
seed suits have like special washing
power secret magic and it washes their
body hmm
she says I love that we're on a
three-way date right now
ulis a psyche right now this to me was
such a wonderful moment and the I was
surprised when I saw this because I
didn't realize first of all nobody ever
stopped me dead in my tracks eating a
slice like that if there's one the
person you've been beefing with for six
months confess her love for you and
cause you go ten and ten in front of
your wife actually I think though when
this really came up was when she said
that my eating pizza was turnt was
turning her on and in that moment I
didn't know what to do but I can't
believe that first of all I'm proud of
you for capturing that in because oh
yeah great moment yeah because sometimes
the best moments are you know there's
who goes without saying anything at all
and it takes a true switchman to know
through solid employer I would say yeah
I know that's a good point
Ian do you have any uh words of
gratitude to me yes thank you I feel
like this is a versatile mean format to
be honest this is like when she says
that when she says that she used people
when there was pubic Pizza great this
when she says that the cheese is vegan
funny hilarious get a lot of people
Ethan you Tricia said you have beef with
Dan
we should bring Dan here we should
confront that you know I wanted to ham
up their beef more but yeah things were
going good and frankly Dan Dan was
definitely dodging it I don't know how I
could have brought it more to light the
beef between Dan and Tricia cuz Dan has
expressed a lot his distaste for Tricia
and that he didn't even want her on the
show at all but how do you feel how do
you feel about that now knowing that you
know it was such a hit episode no I I
admit I was wrong I thought it would be
the bad kind of cringe it turned out to
be the good kind of grace Jimmy Lee
cringe is what we're well Jimmy Lee I'm
happy to say still holds the title of
worst episode is she you know that bus
it was so bad that I we almost consider
not even posting it wow that was loud
okay but that's very much Jimmy Lee
Jimmy Lee has been should I disclose the
recent publication probably not well
Jimmy Lee emails me every day really
stay in touch you're awfully thin me I'm
awful oh yeah he'll my awful playing my
video and bye oh yeah this is a choker
meme playing my video inviting me on the
show you just want it to make fun of me
you're just like the rest hey guys I'm
sorry we gotta go on break Dan saved my
life now we're getting into some other
memes this goes back to the mayonnaise
of Oh am i left to talk about this Ian I
mean you could look at the meme you know
thank you so this goes back to Ian
eating the meme this is a constitutional
convention you got the fan the wild card
the viewers and other contestants is how
are they were writing in the
Constitution right well and you know
correctly for such for such a
technicality semantics a ian is offering
up mayonnaise essentially and accept his
offer this is another great one this is
locked up on a favorite of the Soudan
spoken about can you a mat like yeah I
will I can't I mean damn what kind of
sick mind put this together I've done
what is this girl getting her to
something but the way she is sitting and
the two ponytails is so I think she has
braces on sister being to make her look
as young as possible the guys are like
you know it's my ultimate fantasy a
twelve-year-old girl getting why am I in
there so let's see Dan Idaho girl really
girl mystery girl the broken rules of H
three in well everybody's jumping up
yeah I don't know that should attract
[ __ ] in they just wanted the chips in
their burn enough oh you know I'm all
the chips in there which is fair but my
god why don't you guys watch this actual
video and get back to me Zach you're up
for it I feel like this video should be
illegal I'm gonna see some ID this is
like dark web [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm
saying black comm is such a sit it's
like you don't know if that's what
that's wrong we don't know that uh what
else do you think I guarantee you this
is black too calm who else would put
together such an insomniac shop or my
dude okay did they mess up with the
proportions too like how is the couch so
low compared to the guys
it's very they look like they're a
massive I think well first of all they
probably are quite big and yeah probably
short but I think they also got a really
low couch to make it look like yeah they
were super tall but if she stood up on
the floor her face would probably be
like you know bellybutton level that guy
on the right is huge
he's dicks probably the size of her
goddamn [ __ ] like forearm the rules
of broken walls of
nobody calls dropouts on pornhub a lot
of poor memes so is this just Dan with a
mouth full of Manning that is not me I
mean adult-film website colette calm oh
it's not black sorry my dude Wow I'm
gonna trade [ __ ] you Dan I feel so
betrayed that this isn't black comm
they're gonna step their [ __ ] up or not
well if they're trying to sell black
they better step their [ __ ] up to their
audience I mean I'm not their audience
but they better step it up I'm talking
huge black [ __ ]
with a tiny white little girl and tiny
couches to make those size difference
look more extreme do you know what I'm
saying
no yeah you do this is you in thoughts
on this there's a lot of memes here
listen let's move along in the intern in
the celery employees Winnie the Pooh
that this was about the feeding window
Cecila as a farmer and my tastes on a
pig this is her the feeling window at
the clock accurate it's so awesome
accurate so there you go who remembers
act create thank you for submitting the
memes everybody I was a lot of fun you
know there's spin every time there's a
small gust of wind in LA the whole damn
city catches fire and I woke up
what what what day was this it was a was
it when there was two Monday Sunday yeah
I was about I was just about to fall
asleep I'm up really late because I was
taking care of Theodore just about to
fall asleep and you get these I guess
they're called reverse 9-1-1 but it's
like the amber alert where your phone
was like a and the corollary broadcast
it's not in barrel well amber alert is
specifically a missing child oh that's
what Amber Alert means but so the
process of sending out those warnings is
called a reverse 911 and so my phone
reads firing and and then it's released
the specific neighborhood
she's like literally probably you know
less than a mile away from me I get
ready to evacuate and I'm like what
because I've been up all night and I
didn't I didn't hear anything but I was
hearing a lot of helicopters overhead
and it's fire season so I was wondering
I wonder if there's a fire and I go and
I look out my my window you know and
this is what I see let me show you guys
this was crazy
check this [ __ ] out yeah we got a HD
sitting here 360 max
nice so that's just outside the window
at like 3 o'clock 3 a.m. it's just this
intense orange glow and that smoke I
mean it was really close you can see
yeah you can really see how close it is
on this hill here when I woke up I was
just I was staring at it for like five
minutes and just really remember when
George Washington heard that 911 that
the air planes hit the World Trade aah
and he just sat there silently for like
ten minutes what I ain't talking that's
how I was looking out this window cuz I
just sat down I was watching it you know
do you know that scene it's famous from
what
yeah when when George walk away
Tennessee Washington
slow down George Bush he was reading a
book to a bunch of kids and you see a
Secret Service man come and whisper
something in his ears and he just sits
there for ten minutes like a [ __ ]
just paralyzed and he had said sir
wander attack and George Bush was just
sitting there paralyzed
I don't was such a was that so bizarre
I'm captivated by that anyway that was
me I just sat down and watched this for
five minutes and I was like Frank and
then I got damn boiler that woke up and
I'm like what is happening and you told
me check the window and I looked out the
window I'm like this is actually
happening like this is my nightmare yeah
this is
actually happening so and then like how
do you started packing now we have a
baby so so ela was going like a madman
like she was a freaking going crazy
packing everything I will you know we
were packing with yet my brother was
visiting now we got super lucky because
a new brother is so funny because he
gets all scientific whenever you ask him
a question yeah anything
Ethan was asking him like how bad is it
for us how much time do we have or
something like that and he starts
explaining to us like I don't know I
don't know how to describe it but just
super scientific detailed explanation
well he's more interested in doing this
detailed explanation than evacuate and
I'm like I got a pack and yeah I can't
listen right now sorry I gotta run in
pack um but we got super lucky because
the wind was blowing it and away from us
essentially yeah we got so lucky man if
the one was going to other direction we
would have been so freaked oh yeah what
I was saying is there was a guy here
that I was writing for five minutes when
I was out there by myself and he was
just with a hose spraying oh my god I
was like holy crap like where how close
is his fire it was just a guy right here
just spraying not just spraying like
this I was like oh my god did I don't
think that garden hose is gonna stop
that fire but anyway it wasn't a
firefighter it was just somebody no yeah
yeah no no boy yeah just some what the
garden hose I just saw water squirting
like this like a you know and that'll
stop it dude
for sure well from this hillside it must
have looked like a hellscape yeah
because they would have seen everything
and I'm just seeing the orange glow but
anyway it burned the other way they got
suited like this is right next to us and
then it's just all I guess one Dadar
direction and now there's like a huge
mandatory evacuation zone there and it
took my poor mom three hours to get to
our house today to babysit Theodore
three hours man it took you guys a while
to get yeah
right yeah Tukey in like two hours to
get to work usually take some 20 minutes
what happened was just bumper-to-bumper
because like the 405 is closed from the
fire and then the 101 someone tried to
kill themselves on it last night
like I'm related to the fire that closed
down traffic correct so yeah do it if
you're gonna kill yourself do it on a
different day yeah a weekend or
something
exactly did you listen anything good in
the car you what do you do to entertain
yourself
I listen to the county album if you guys
okay that's a good transition Jesus is
king tell me about your the new album is
out to everyone I don't know where yes
Ian tell me about your reception to the
new album still taking it in but I don't
hate it it's not my favorite it's lower
on his albums if I were to rank him but
I like it more than a lot of people a
lot of people really hate it and there's
a lot in there that I enjoy a whole
whole lot so now how many times have you
listened to it probably yeah you're
still taking it in ah I got a piece so
bad I feel like you're liking it less
because when you first heard it you were
super jacked about it but now you're
saying that here it's not your favorite
well I still like it a lot like my least
favorite album of his is better than
most albums all here you know in a year
but I do have issues with the album and
the messaging of them there's certain
things that I'm tell me about might
agree with like the religious aspect no
I don't mind that oh I just feel like
there's certain he's like comparing
himself to these religious figures and I
feel like he's drawing a parallel
between himself and Jesus versus like
being a follower of Jesus I feel his ego
very heavily in the album which I feel
like conflicts with kind of the
Christian ideals he's trying to get
across and just kind of muddied I
suppose certainly don't think that
that's the point of
gianna t to say that I am Jesus do you
think Jesus already did it
dan didn't like it dan hated it dan has
been messing with Dan no I'm just
trolling him for the most part because I
know the saturation is pretty wild on
your camera I don't know what you look
like a beauty vlogger you notice how
when you watch all these Beauty vloggers
on YouTube they do this yeah exactly
they do this crazy saturation so you
can't see any blemishes or details I
don't know it this it's a stupid webcam
so it like Ottawa Justin for some reason
it's going crazy I know okay well as
long as you look worse than me then we
got no problem right ela I don't know I
saw Kanye on chemo he gave me Kimball
and I wasn't sure about him he's kind of
like well he was going on so there was a
guy in the crowd a black guy who won the
lottery yeah a big big Jack [ __ ] like
hundreds of millions and he was wearing
a good shoe jacket mhm and probably to
that guy he always wanted a good chief
never afford it so that's the first
thing you buy me it's like a 89 you
looking good feeling good I would do the
same thing mm-hmm
so Kanye was like look at me I'm wearing
a cheap hoodie and you're wearing a
Gucci jacket you may just want to think
about how you're gonna invest your money
like we should educate it we want it or
you need to be an example to the people
people should educate one another about
how to invest your money and it's like
that I just couldn't believe that was
Sonja first of all is merch alone cause
like Ian could tell you a lot of money
just for a Maruti and okay you were
wearing a cheap hoodie that one day but
you're like it's probably not that cheap
by the way it was it nice it's probably
not that cheap he's like this hoodie
only cost 200 bucks
yeah the cheapest hoodie I own yeah how
much was his March you went to see his
shows at the Forum yeah I did
how much was his merch there the
sweaters were around like
2:54 crewneck yeah that's what Jesus
would solve for his murder
can you imagine that that Jesus merch
back in the day I'd be so it I just give
the guy a break you won the lotto that's
when you buy a Gucci jacket treat
yourself
but his whole thing was like we have to
be a we have to uplift our community and
teach them that when you get money you
don't it's not all about the Gucci
jacket but have you seen Kanye's house
by the way right yeah we made a video I
mean that guy is the definition look at
his wife his wife is literally the
symbol of like excess his family is the
symbol of excess and then also he has
lyrics on the new album that there's a
line that says like that's the reason
why I charge the prices that I charge I
don't want my family to starve I don't
want to be on Dancing with the Stars you
seized all activities your family wanted
star for like hundreds of years
well Kim Kardashian's richer than he is
so together together it's than Kylie's a
billionaire also he bragged on he also
bragged on Jimmy Kimmel he's like I'm a
billionaire and I'm wearing a cheap
hoodie it's like good for you dude
what car did you drive in what house do
you live in what plane do you fly it's
like who cares that you're wearing a
cheap hoodie I don't know he's gotten
he's I have to say that appearance on
Kimble Kimble Kimble
I offer saying Kimble was a little bit
cream gee Ian did you watch it
he watched it who you kiddin cause I
watched it I I didn't see that one I
sent it on our chat no one watched it I
didn't watch it I watched a brief clip
or nOCO I watched 10 seconds of it and I
bailed because I can't [ __ ] stand him
he's kind of doing it this whole douchey
thing it's like he's you he's hijacking
the religion just to kind of give
himself even more of an ego boost
cuz he's because when you when you go
through on the crusade like the
religious crusade it gives you this
moral high ground and he's definitely
exploiting that moral high
ground all the way bike yeah I'm
Christian everything I wear cheap hoodie
I'm christ-like and he said he works for
Jesus and I don't know how he said it
exactly but like now all of his
existence is just to serve ro you want
to prove to me that that you you're
really in donate all your money donate
now you're sending your money no don't
think that's gonna happen well I don't
care about him having money I just but I
like that he's like pointing out this
poor guy that yes but also you don't
know what that guys doing first
community show me your closet Konya
probably could sell his closet for a few
Millions you don't know what he's doing
for his community he's wearing a Gucci
jacket you don't got a single that poor
guy out you know what I mean his good
fortune yeah I feel like his messaging
here is so muddied and confused the
music I still think the music sounds
really good mm-hmm but his actual
direction of content and lyrically and
how he's conveying his ideas seems kind
of worse than ever so well yeah I think
I'm gonna agree with you even though I
haven't listened to it yet but I think
like just from the little snippets that
he's been posting I like the sound of it
but I don't know he's very talented per
dir he's a very talented musician I've
always had my eats but I think lyrically
he's always kind of a well I don't know
I can't say always but I don't know the
guy needs to just what's your advice for
him in he's listening what if he's
listening right now what would you say
to Kanye to give me a call I'll tell him
I'll tell him what he's got to do no I
just feel like cop-out I feel like he
needs to like he's doing like he made a
point to not swear on this whole album
like he's doing these gestures that feel
kind of hollow but he's not actually
kind of digging into like the effects of
like what it actually means to live a
life like in Christ like a christ-like
life
he just says like I love God that's the
only idea this whole album is like God
is cool guy that's cool but I feel like
it's so much more complex than that it's
a lot about overcoming overcoming
hardships and how difficult that may be
the struggles that can come out of
something you know I feel like there
could have been something substantial
there well if you listened to his first
big single it's called jesus walks and
that song alone is way more complex
ideas than this entire album put
together in my opinion seems like it was
rushed
yeah well anyway enough about anyway
congratulations to Nina and Kanye and
two cars to love the and to Kanye who
was slumming it in his $200 hoodie what
how christ-like I mean it doesn't get
more christ-like than that so how much
is the hoodie you're wearing right now I
am uh-oh oh and I hope this is cheap
this is you know I'm not wearing a 250 I
saw I got in line and then what am i
doing I decided I was like I was like
the teaching of this album would not
approve me of getting sweater maybe it's
a test
it's a loyalty test yeah and it worked
well let's throw it to a break and when
we come back we got to talk about the
feeding window ela hates to admit that
it's working and we're gonna the cast is
gonna be participating in no not
November yes even you Zack okay we will
be discussing that later on and of
course our main stories which you know
what they are because they're in the
title we've got oh and a salad taste
test that's gonna be coming up we should
probably do that ASAP because that [ __ ]
is not getting better with age
regardless let's throw to break we'll be
right back god bless Kanye West god
bless
I don't know just cut to me just got me
a nice pair of sheets we all deserve at
least that and you cannot possibly
appreciate how much it makes a
difference when you're in bed enjoying
your sleep than having a beautiful high
quality pair of sheets it breathes you
don't get as hot it's soft it's lovely
it's beautiful this is it
Brooke linens got the answer people are
loving and recommending Brooke linen
calm you want to know why they won
winner of best online bedding category
by Good Housekeeping they have reviews
from Business Insider Apartment Therapy
and men's health raving 35,000 five-star
reviews more than any other online
betting company at half a million happy
sleepers and gowning you can include me
in that their mission is to make you
more comfortable their sheets don't just
feel great but they look great too you
can mix and match over 20 colors and
patterns my Brooklyn sheets are the most
comfortable sheets that I have ever
slept on their tails have turned my
bathroom into a spa I could recommend
them more for friends family or just
treating yourself to the upgrade you
deserve Brooke linen calm is giving an
exclusive offer just for my listeners
get 10% off and free shipping when you
use the promo code h3 at Brooklyn and
calm Brooke linen is so confident in
their product and their sheets
comforters towels they come with a
lifetime warranty the only way to get
10% off and free shipping is to use the
promo code h3 at Brooklyn in.com that's
BR okay li any n.com promo code h3
Brooklyn these are gonna be the best
sheets that you have ever slept
ela I know you believe in working smart
more than just working because sometimes
you could work and you don't get work
done but when you work smart you work
less and you get more work done
that's where kaptara comes in kaptara
helps you find the right software for
your needs fast so you can get back to
business even faster at kaptara you can
compare thousands of software options
read reviews and instantly narrow down
your favorites you'll have more time in
no time find the right software right
now at kaptara comm / h3 kaptara is the
leading free online resource to help you
find the best software solutions for
your business with over 1 million
reviews of products from real software
users discover everything you need to
make an informed decision you can search
for more than 700 specific categories of
software everything from project
management to email marketing to yoga
studio management software yes people it
does get that niche join the millions of
people who use kaptara each month to
find the right tools for their business
we use kaptara to find some software for
four content management system to manage
the tasks we have an in-house I pile
[ __ ] up on Ian how to make sure you make
this good keep him busy to earn that
salary just got promoted - and it works
we found one that really works for us
yet all we I'm telling you kaptara do it
is you gonna get some so for the super
ultra productive visit kept air.com / h
sleep for free today to buy the tools to
make an informed software decision for
your business kaptara dot-com / h 3
kaptara that c AP te r ra dot-com / h3
its kaptara baby software selection
simplified we are back why did Zack
count us in where is bad we're stance
cuz I had to sit in cos iam was late
come back Oh Zack you gotta grab that
voted a fiery end no I'm here Oh Bobby
Lee's here Oh Bobby Lee came storming
into our office yeah because I wouldn't
tell you why I'm here now when I tell
your audio
everything I'm gonna tell your audience
everything go ahead I believe I believe
that things happen for a reason
I believe there's destiny okay now when
I was a young man did I believe that
there was a fat Jewish man that had my
body my ugliness my own sexuality my nan
cool you know stiff you know yeah and I
did I think that no but did I met you
hmm and we are now you know you're the
Jew version of this career yeah it could
be right yeah so when I met you I
thought there's something you two I love
but we also have like our you know these
better halves I know we do but because I
did your podcast mhm I met a therapist
in your building mm-hmm it was a really
good session that's I feel like I knew
Bobby Lee is around the corner so I
thought and I'm gonna lighten everyone
soon hey you need to come back come
check back in every week and I'm gonna
be here every Tuesday yeah cuz I'm gonna
go in no yeah I'll come in and I was
molested but you know what that wasn't
my fault
Wow okay well that's a bit that was a
big is that now how would I just before
you go you're such a fashion icon
I like what you're wearing can you know
what can I say something when I went and
bought your [ __ ] beanie at that store
I had no idea he was [ __ ] yours
that's all and when I know it was
[ __ ] yours I try to return it because
but you know what net but no the reason
why I bought it is because it's my
quality is this it yeah that's it I love
it it's high-quality - I didn't mean to
make you talk about ice I really like
what you're wearing like this shirt and
now tell me about the first session yet
I mean did you go in because I know like
the first sessions usually like getting
to know you but did you go in for the
heavy [ __ ] already or did are you kind
of like what's hard because we're
podcasters yeah and all the things that
I've said I've said surprises in front
of everyone yeah I think my eye
use this as therapy that's true but then
the people listening they didn't give me
the right advice like you do cuz they
work at like you know that that's in
beyond or that which is not a bad job if
you were to work at Bed Bath & Beyond
you know you don't have exactly the
qualifications to analyze right that's
like they don't have it right so I think
by doing it this way because the things
that she was saying he was very clear to
me good I think I'm gonna go see her -
can we all use the same it's in your
podcast studio because it's like oh like
I work out with her well I'm gonna well
you know me when it's [ __ ] doesn't work
out I will I burn the bridge I'll you
know I mean I'll ruin it for everybody
yeah I'll make sure she never sees you
again yeah ask you something about your
fate because when I'm on Instagram
sometimes yeah and I'll scroll by your
[ __ ] face okay you'll do something so
you've with your body so [ __ ] so
crazy
you ruin my appetite ruin the way I feel
about that moment really yeah so what's
that about friend wait how you doing
yeah it gets pretty elaborate oh wait
the pill put it like on the floor and
stand on a chair and shred it like
really and you have to set a time right
before you in the room when he's doing
it yeah sometimes I'm flicking the big
star funny yeah I mean I think it's fun
it's not like magic you're like covering
your face like no it's not like you're
right it's not tragic you're right but
could I see this leave mm-hmm I just I
really do mean this that I honestly on
group level and everyone listening to me
right now god bless you and take care
okay mark these two here when you're
listening to these two I'm not kidding
you daliyah everyone we love you you
know and you and we look at you guys as
stand-ups we look at you guys as real
how many community people right and I
love you guys so much and I consider you
guys family I'm gonna leave right now
right god bless take care good night
oh by the way my sister and brother last
saw you an ox our dealer I thought you
were amazing I don't think so but they
thought they thought you were a great
eye I want to say it next time your
family's at my show I don't want to
bother you more handsome up close I have
to say you gained a couple of points of
attraction up close he has nice skin and
like I got pictures of him from kalila
sleeping with the beanie yeah man that
guy doesn't they're real I'm glad he's
talking to somebody everyone it's
therapy is he still here is he just
walked out well that that's a that was a
treat you got to get the Bobby weakly
check yeah he's the best
those guys are so sweet they're too nice
Chris and Bobby what Cossacks speaking
of a feeding window either do you have
any comments on the feeding window so I
told you things yesterday that I hated
made the but it seems like it's working
I'll tell you what's great about the
feeding window for me I give myself an
eight-hour feeling window so for me it's
between 10:00 and 6:00 that perfectly
captures for me two meals and after 6:00
when I wrap it up I can it just works
really well for me that I can just say
okay I'm not eating anymore where
usually I would just be snacking eating
cereal grabbing this and that and all
those calories are gonna add up big-time
I'm talking like an extra five six seven
eight hundred but many times having even
an extra meal at 10 p.m. because ela
doesn't he and that she gets hungry and
then we're like oh let's order food so I
think when you set those restrictions on
yourself at least for me it really works
so I thought at first that it wasn't
gonna be like that I thought you were
gonna go like crazy during the fitting
window no
I mean I'm not stuck like I'm not going
out of my way to stuff myself I'm eating
know but somehow you also it seems like
you're eating more responsibly even
during the window well because you know
you're trying to lose weight so you're a
little more conscious but I'm eating
what I want I'm you know what I mean I'm
not suffering and it's you is it's hard
for the first couple hours after the
window closes but you get over it and
then I'm fine but I just I love the idea
by feeding window to cuz it does make me
feel like a pig and a truck in sounds so
bad the window is open the window is
closed it's like I like the whole action
of a window opening and closing so
sceeto out of the question I don't mind
I don't buy keto there's something about
eating hamburger patties and cheese get
bacon to me that sounds absolutely
repulsive and wrong it doesn't have to
be I don't like it can be other things
I'm just
I like the feeding windows I don't rock
the boat okay you can open line the good
didn't mean you can go mind with the
feeling with I'm I'm frankly I watched a
documentary about veganism on Netflix
and I was like damn that sounds pretty
good so I'm thinking about going vegan
to phase phasing out yeah you tried that
last year that lasted like a week I'm
true I think though you tried and you
end up getting wait wait
I think I'm there's a lot of vegan
products so I feel like if I really make
that effort like vegan chicken wing I
even tried vegan yogurt it's yogurt made
from cashews and it was great that's
good um vegan food has come really far
in the last decade are you really far
I'm really down and I'm just waiting for
you to say the word but you're not going
vegan no I can't do yes I want to go
vegetarian I do really think I could
phase out of eating meat for me I like
eggs and cheese is almost like all I eat
so I really don't think it would be good
no you should keep eating that but the
vegan products like Dan said are getting
so good that you can enjoy your meals
too
level and that you really could with
meat and you really don't even notice
the difference I mean these impossible
burgers are slamming yeah it really
satisfies me in the same way Zach just
tried an impossible burger for the first
time today
Zach I was pleasantly surprised I just
tried it like a week ago for the first
time it's great it's yeah it's very good
actually enjoyed it better because I
wasn't thinking in my head like I think
I have a problem with meat because I
find it so gross and I'm always
wondering like what am i eating and I'm
paranoid about like what's in my bite I
don't know if it makes sense so yeah
knowing that there was no meat and it
kind of made it more enjoyable for me I
understand what you mean because you you
have a strong aversion to like gristle
and yeah and all that which is I mean I
don't blame you also I just I love
animals I really do yeah and I just I
mean it's just so messed up the animal
slaughter houses and farms and you know
on one hand it's like those are gonna
exist I mean there's really nothing to
do about it until we have such a strong
and effective alternative to meet the of
glabra meat but at the same time coming
it would be nice to not participate yet
to not participate in that I mean I love
my dogs and pigs and cows are as smart
or smarter than dogs mm-hmm I mean it's
not it's not good it's not good to to to
do what we're doing to those animals
yeah so well anyway the feeding window
is good I like it now here's something
else that I think is gonna be more
controversial no not November now it was
suggested that we as a team try no not
November okay me and Dan and Zach now no
nut November means no sex right and no
masturbating oh I thought it was just no
masturbating well if you're having sex
then I mean
and well who cares about masturbating
true so you can't have sex for a month I
think will you having sex with your
business Dan tell me about what I think
that the reason that it's about
masturbating is because well I saw that
post on the subreddit and the fan said
that like you've talked about how you
can't go a day without mm-hmm
masturbating mm-hmm so that's why it's
not about sex
so you think that as we as long as we
don't well Dan how many times you jerk
off in a month I just pulled up the
rules it is it does include sex you
cannot have sex masturbate or not in any
way shape or form watching pornography
and having boners are allowed but you
can't nut that's something awful why
would you want to watch why would you
want to do it silently watching porn
like watching a good pic on it's all
it's awesome like hocus-pocus we should
wash you anyway weird [ __ ] yeah it's not
it's not good for you I'm sorry just
watching porn and nacho golf that seems
psycho that's like clockwork orange'
[ __ ] Oh make you go like go [ __ ]
shoot up a kindergarten okay we don't
know November I could do without the
jerking off but well the no sex affects
your partner tell ya the implication is
that like women don't like sex it's like
well you're part of it too apparently
gives you super powers what we talked
about it I want to say last year I
remember pretty much we had a lot of
fans emailing us saying you know it
boosts your serotonin in your brain or
something and and you know and I mean
after they tried it they felt more alive
and more active and blah blah blah
there's no way the science to that I
think
you know I just feel alive for the first
time not jerking off this month I have
friends who go I don't I don't have no
idea how this came up in conversation
but he was saying that he liked doesn't
jerk off at all and I was like what he
says I didn't work off at all just
because he doesn't feel like it I'm like
bro this I don't know what this has to
do with anything but I was shocked by
that
I guess there's people that they were
just know not November through their
whole life people have different levels
of libido I don't want to honestly yeah
honestly don't that does Lobito every
guy just got a jerk off
it's like the feeding window for
masturbating does that make sense
honestly there's a Twitter account that
follows the podcast on Twitter and just
post a picture of Danny just as honestly
to everything and it's pretty good it
has a lot of engagement action honestly
what are your thoughts on that and I've
been enjoying it yeah it's funny I
wonder if it's the same guy as the
Gazebo I had a severe yeah it's the same
guy who does the gazebo is the same guy
that does posting pictures of Ethan and
responds to the gazebo
[Laughter]
honestly we're really taking a long time
to get through this document
I've only I mean I'm not even the actual
topic let's just get to the point here
mr. beast is trying to plant 20 million
trees ah how nice it is nice mr. Bies
hit 20 million subscribers and
celebrated 20 million subscribers he
wants to plant 20 million trees team
trees org how much have they raised now
I think it was like six as of last night
but as of now only six and a half
trees planted man he might actually make
it we're trying to get 20 million trees
planted by 2020 so every dollar is a
tree right so apparently every dollar
he's working with the sir day yeah Arbor
Day some nonprofit charity that just
plants trees like Johnny Appleseed
except not apple trees but other kinds
of trees as well then try to plant 20
million trees by 2020 no this is a nice
thing you know is this going to solve
climate change
no is it nice that they're doing it is
it I like to see our generation being
you know activate it because ultimately
all these old [ __ ] booming
[ __ ] are destroying the planet
burning trees burning fossil fuels
bringing back coal they don't give a
[ __ ] and ultimately we're the ones and
especially even the younger generation
is the ones that are gonna have to pay
for this planet that's that that's being
ruined what and then you feel so
helpless what can I do what can I
actually do right what using a paper
straw no you know I mean like yes but no
so that's how I feel about everything I
feel like even twelve twenty million
trees it's like but they're trying
something it's a lot of trees I'm sure
that's look this one science shuttle
that's collaborating with them what size
channel was it it was um I don't I don't
want ropers I want to give ya mark Roper
Roper he's the guy that did the glitter
bomb glitters terrible for the
environment
oh man that disabilities led him on yeah
did you see legitimized all the trees
honestly no mark Roper he explained that
you know trees grow they get their
carbon from the air they basically are
giant carbon deposits and they suck
carbon out and they leave oxygen for us
to breathe and since the inception of
human civilization half of all trees on
planet earth have been destroyed there's
a lot of carbon being released into the
environment the question is how many of
the trees
they planned will actually last and for
how long because apparently needs to
last like a hundred years to make a
difference mm-hmm and not not a lot of
them are going to us well they know he
says in his video that they are working
with this nonprofit who is very good at
planting trees and ensuring a high
survivability rate for these reason the
part that I end apparently they work
with local ordinance and governance and
the planting trees on the right
ecosystem because it's like what are you
gonna do just go plant a tree and Park I
mean you know what I mean it has to be
in the right place yeah so this
organization is logistic about these
things logistically and it's a global
initiative it's not just the United
States
so will it have a measurable difference
on climate change who knows is it a
beautiful and great thought I mean I
think so I think it's great I like it in
a time when this climate crisis feels
you know unsurmountable and that people
just don't care enough about it
I mean hey so nice to try to do
something I'm gonna donate I'm gonna
give a thousand bucks when I get home so
I planted a thousand trees mother effers
so who says that I'm not the best guy
ever next time let him know let's see
the idea came from a fan who tweeted
what should I give my 20 millionth sub
and that petition said plant twenty
million trees and his video announcement
mr. B said that he had been spammed
about the position the petition so much
that he had to do it and he became began
the project by personally planting
hundreds of trees in Oregon the website
is called team trees org there's
actually some really big donations here
I'll read to you guys so we've got I
know strees mister beasts gave the three
or two hundred thousand Wow wait hundred
thousand others two different ones oh
you're right juicy juicy tree that's
juicy tree plant oh it's because
somebody one-upped him so he had to
one-up that's only fair I guess I don't
know who Alan Walker is but good job to
you
Ukraine the snug thus the country of
Ukraine thank you to them
mark Roper that's the guy we talked
about 50,000 jeffree star 50,000 the odd
one out he's an animator 33,000 another
animation Walker is a musician by the
way I just oh how nice of him
ninja is planting 15,000 tree a lot of
influence resumed Todd blossom I realize
you know big money yeah big money for
the forest well I'm only given 1000 now
I feel like a cheap [ __ ]
I'll tell you right now I want to give
less if I'm being totally honest right
now maybe I'll give a hundred just don't
want to be left out where were you and
those trees were being planted
maybe I'll just plant a tree and say I
participated III bet you I bet you I
could plant a tree for fifty cents I'm
gonna send Danny and Zach over the park
recipe just plant some trees all day
I'll make you guys think you can get in
there I'll have them these guys plant 20
trees I'll probably cost me 50 bucks
call it a day that actually is more yeah
that's alright I'll donate it doesn't I
take it all back what the hell it's a
see all coming soon come on what kind of
Fitness is not that technical of a
feature coming soon why do you have a
clickable links is coming soon right
anyway good job everyone so we we I mean
look we started getting a little
skeptical about it and we looked into
the not skeptical but you wonder ok you
were giving twenty million dollars to
this organization that's gonna plant a
bunch of trees it's like okay yeah
what's the chances that somebody's not
actually just making money off this well
we looked up up on Charity Navigator
which is a it's a website that
rates charities uh based on financial
accountability and transparency and they
actually have a very good rating I was
happy to see so there you go
eighty six point seven eight out of a
hundred financial they have eighty one
point eighty one percent and account
building transparency ninety six percent
so they have some executives who are
making a little cheddar cheese but
ultimately ultimately that's that's fine
I mean administrative expenses three
percent fundraising so fourteen percent
I wonder if that's I mean you got to
spend money on fundraising it's like oh
just of simple returns right liability
and assess assets so this stuff is
websites so interesting fifty million
damn these guys are pretty flush so
mister beasts is gonna up that really
cool so it's a good charity actually you
don't have to worry about that they are
definitely a good charity and so for
those reasons I'm proud to announce that
I'll be donating $100 to them but those
reasons I'm in for those reasons I'm in
and I'll be donating $50 after this
episode airs to help support the
initiative okay I'm just trying to be
funny cuz it keeps going getting less
every time I know okay nobody was
laughing I thought it was funny but then
again don't doesn't stop people from
hating let's see people were hating
articles about this never cite a
specific examples with the Beggs example
I could find there's a doomsday
subreddit they say that's why I'm
laughing my ass off that this team tree
[ __ ] going around in social media
since yesterday all the YouTube stars
are promoting it for the gen Z guys just
STFU it's too late and I bet my left not
someone is profiting from this well I
just disapproved that it's too late I
still like trees [ __ ] still got
need shade even if though if it isn't
too late right that's what that's like
the argument
get about like these people who who are
like so against trying to do anything
about the quality of our air and
removing co2 from that miss fear it's
like bro clean air is a good thing even
if you think that global climate change
is a chinese hoax clean air is Delp i
don't think they think it's a hoax they
just think it's too late to do anything
no well not damn the flip side of it but
you're right some people yeah
plant a lot of people thinks that it's
[ __ ] yeah that it's just some
liberal conspiracy to fleece people's
money mm-hmm I mean Donald Trump our
president thinks that he famously said
that global warming is a Chinese hoax
global climate change is a Chinese hoax
whoa so that's a good definitely
represents my beliefs more serious
criticism can be leveled that this let's
see four different groups of scientists
responded with critique one of their big
concerns is that placing too much
attention on tree planting takes away
from the most important steps to
stopping a climate catastrophe which is
cutting down on burning fossil fuels
well you can do both at the same time
exactly why are you quitting it's like
why you can't such a hater as [ __ ] yeah
okay how am i stand the logic it's like
you know the planting the trees is is in
a way trying to band-aid the root of the
issue not yeah nobody says hey guys why
don't we both need to happen you know
also what are we doing about using less
fossil fuel anyway it's like it's such a
big problem on an individual basis you
can't do anything you need a huge
systemic governmental change you need a
huge sweeping reform our entire economy
is dependent on fossil fuels we can't
undo that on an individual level yeah we
need to like and I get why these people
are get frustrated like you mentioned
before the thing with the straws like
that's you know I know people's heart is
in the right place but that's done
that's not
doing anything but nobody's like that
actually even if it's small that
actually can have a little bit of an
impact well you know bearing in mind
that nearly half of the world's trees
have been destroyed since the you know
human civilization I think that's a
beautiful thing to do yeah trees are
dope
love trees we're not that'd be
interesting hmm
hate trees so I just hates trees I think
Donald Trump pitch trees I think he said
that liking trees is the Chinese hope I
like it I'm proud of them I'm proud of
everybody it's a great initiative
personally I just like to see it's like
I've seen lots of successful charities
I've seen lots of successful initiatives
among my you know contemporaries my
peers on on YouTube but I haven't seen
one that addresses the issue of climate
change and it's such a hotly contested
issue I mean the scientific community
overwhelmingly there's a consensus there
I mean that's undebatable but there's a
lot of political spin that that is
somehow made this a partisan issue
climate change and so it's nice to see
people putting that savanna side and
agreeing together that this is an issue
that needs to be that's important to to
them so I like that I find that to be
hopeful and nice so with that being said
and and let's bring out some salads
because we are helping the second now
here we've got an this is my dream
segment as you know we become fond of
eating food doing taste tests often fast
food here on the podcast mm-hmm well Eve
us been complaining that I'm just using
it as an excuse to fast food and get fat
so is it okay you'll let me stick it to
you here's what we're gonna do this week
we are going to taste test
fast food salads No
you are telling the story like it was
your idea but it actually was not it was
my idea
it was not what it was a fan it was a
fan you're totally right it wasn't my
idea I thought it was my idea but now I
remember
Thank You Zach go ahead tell the story
when we were at the Meetup and now I'm
not I'm looking at my phone not because
I'm talking to Jesus but because I'm
looking for the picture when we were at
the meetup in New York one of the fans
that came to us said that he had an idea
for me that we do a solid taste test
because he always gets pissed that we
just see eating all this grows faster
Darius and I was like damn that's a good
idea
and then I took it as my own then I'm
I'm gonna send you the picture are you
presenting this right Dan come on just
show it to the camera we'll do it later
that guy knows okay yeah that's you dude
that's the dude you did it
and I was like damn that's a good idea
let me forget that I ever met you and
just take that as my own so I think this
is gonna be fun because look at these
pictures by the way this is McDonald's
right in a glass bowl here we're going
we'll go in that order actually that'll
make it easy Rd we start at the top a
beautiful little side salad Burger King
mmm grilled chicken salad yeah it looks
good that's definitely fried chicken
that's not grilled chicken a what is
that mushrooms was that chicken
that's chicken okay
Taco Bell that's got to be the dirtiest
that's the one I'm gonna eat
and finally Wendy's apple pecan come on
don't make gourmet cells okay let's go
let's start with McDonald's all right so
grilled chickens Southwest salad that's
going to be this guy right here I
believe
remember yeah so uh all right let's have
a look so this is Alana on first
appearance and I say this one doesn't
look that bad by the way let's just pull
this pleasure these were about yesterday
afternoon yeah but to be yeah I mean in
full in full fairness McDonnell's that's
looking pretty good
chicken there chickens a little strange
dude like a strong look you know when
you get chicken out of Airport or like a
bus stop that's exactly when like waves
wrong way why even it chicken I'm just
I'm just trying to image and a Newman's
Own ranch is how you're supposed to eat
with that so that's the real [ __ ] well
at least it's not like McDonald's weird
it's like Newman actually you know about
Newman's Own 100% of profits go to
charity says it right on the that's
[ __ ] cool man they're cool you got a
fort here so guys without further ado
the big exciting taste test
mmm we all shared that ball will share
ten dozen dozen I don't touch the
chicken yeah
the Newman's Own I don't like that much
oh really that's the part that's it okay
all right I'm surprised the first one
grilled chicken Southwest I don't even
know that's the day old yeah the Saudis
dr. Suresh and I'm being honest that's a
good salad
all right so while she's trying that one
I'm gonna stage the second one this I
have a feeling we might be going from
one of the best to one of the worst
right now this is Arby's
I heard the Arby's side of solid I was
like we have got to get that salad and
it's just called the Arby's side salad
let me get a picture oh here it is okay
this is not bad dude that's like a good
salad yeah I'm into that
exactly you bring in a pair of scissors
I'm gonna oh this is a first this is a
date
you lose them we're second five people I
want I'm gonna eat that salad I'm hungry
bye give me that [ __ ] hold on yeah wait
don't worry Dan I got an appetite you
just go in the feeding windows the
windows open when does the window closed
six actually I'm not gonna get home in
time for dinner I'm just gonna silently
you guys talk I can't get this open this
already looks so sad actually I'm
panicking I'm panicking like you always
panic when I'm not bringing stuff in
damn how sad [ __ ] the scissors Zach no
you know how I feel
Zach's hunting the scissors down and not
having any luck there then got it we got
it we got it
bad air this RB salad you slow over that
no yeah so we got some Dijon honey
mustard that's that's what's recommended
girls Ian you had an interesting
experience at Arby's do you want to tell
us what happened when you went to the
Arby's yesterday find it yeah so I went
to order the salad and put yourself on
screen let's go yeah and I get to the
window and this kind of older very
skinny Asian gentleman comes up and he's
like you know oh no I'm so sorry for the
delay we're getting your salad now I
didn't take a while yeah it took a long
time but it didn't seem like anyone was
working besides him and then he's like
he's like so do you know work today huh
I feel like I'm like I'm on lunch break
he's like oh nice what do you do and I'm
I just said oh I'd PA
he's like nice you work around here and
there you want to be in my a I think
that's where I was building up to and I
was like kinda not too close he was like
do you live nearby and I said not really
he said do you live with your parents
what and I said oh that's such a creepy
question what's probably around maybe
like 55th oh yeah and that makes sense
the daddy is a nice juicy little twink
did you get his phone number I did not
and then I said the shame I said well he
asks do you have roommates I said yeah I
do and he was like oh okay
I'm really excited to be talking to you
right now oh wow was it George Takei and
then he finally goes and grabs the salad
it almost looked like it was just
sitting there the whole time
oh my goodness he leans out the window
to hand it to me and then he like gets
close and he like whispers and he's like
come pick me up after work I'm serious
and then I was like what are you wait
you didn't he said come pick me up after
work yeah he actually said that yeah
Arby's drive-through like at raesha
store how did you respond to that yeah I
agree I just kind of went like and then
I drove off did he touch your hand when
you this I was very careful with hand
placement I snagged that bag and got
going yeah wonder if there's any if
there's like date rape in this Wow I'm
wondering like does is he doing that all
day probably is that something you
should like tell Arby's about they're
like listen dude it's Arby's Louie we
just we don't really monitor what goes
on there
like come on they're you wasting our
time the fact that I asked if you live
with your parents that's yeah really
creepy I think yous trying to figure out
like how am I gonna be able to come over
and not and no one will be there
honestly well I'll tell you what I'm not
so much worried about the date here get
it I mean I don't really want to taste
this because that dressing I don't know
foul bro you should get it close up you
look you got to see what this looks like
I feel like that's that Asian dudes come
for see sauce dude yeah it's a horse
can we get dancing to be fair it's uh
I'm gonna try it get about it at here we
go to be honest it looks fine let's give
it a try Arby's to the Asian man that
wants to rape you all right but not a
fan of chewing noise Trisha likes me
when I truly love her to be fair I don't
like honey mustard
but the freshness of the lettuce is
pretty good
really yeah that's surprising it's
crunchy the cheese is good the tomatoes
are good the ball itself is very
depressing I just don't know why you
would even get this cuz it's so small
the bull's depressing there's not really
much going on there's an important
factor here that I know you'll find
relevant it's not bad we have you look
we did track the prices on all of these
and all of them are between you know six
and seven dollars
except for this Arby's 1 which is 3 well
it makes sense of more bang for your
buck yeah this McDonald's phone is on
another level I mean this is a meal all
right this is I don't know why you eat
this at Arby's well really wonder how
many of those they sell it there I
really hate sauce the dressing is not
good but just addresses you evaluate it
on the lettuce the lettuce is fine but
this whole thing kind of sucks I don't
know it's kind of a pointless thing yeah
like just don't order
but that that dressing really is [ __ ]
beautiful
yeah I mean I feel like if you order
actually order honey-mustard you've got
a little you have like daddy issues or
something so uh so next up this is a
this is B K this is Burger King which I
personally think is one of the worst
fast-food didn't we rate it like F when
we did the looks like oh it's soggy bun
the Burger King grilled chicken club
Aled yeah and you got some Ken's like
honey balsamic so they are making this
decision for us regarding the dressing
yeah I think it is just kind of a
default mmm you probably get something
else if you asked for it that's so
interesting that they all have a
different one McDonald's ranch way to go
Arby's honey mustard well uh some of
them they didn't have a default
I don't think okay Burger King had a
default actually and then they asked I
said what do you have and then I picked
picked one of them okay
balsamic on a club that's okay say
ranchers I do I would do ranch on all
these yeah they're all ranch very
rancher both salads ranch of all alright
well we're gonna try it with well guy
here we go just a bit you know what I
mean we could do without dressing it
I'll just put a light amount cuz they
don't even make the dressing that's
right this is Ken's get here can you do
she don't even donate your profits well
the chicken looks [ __ ] horrid alright
oh there's bacon bits in here hello
dollars yeah I'm Alex you better try
this get some shots with this yeah
get off let's see that chicken that
chicken ain't right a little flat it
looks like a soggy hamburger bun don't
want puke down there so you don't want
to try this you know you're not allowed
to skip on a taste test why is it so dry
it it's like falling apart it's like
flaky but it tastes actually fine I know
y'all gonna hate on me and call me a
liar but tastes fine the bacon generous
the leaves fine the dressing can okay
this is not them there's way too much
bacon it's super salty it's like there's
so much cheese and bacon in here it
sounded like there was a lot of
positivity yeah happening and then well
I actually got an 80 on us there I was I
was tasting each ingredient sure sure
individually but as a whole of this
salad is probably heavier and more
disgusting in calorie rich than a
hamburger gross
mm-hmm yes so much food and bacon
there's more cheese and bacon than
lettuce
I loved it the McDonald's solid I had
beans and corn mm-hmm
so it's a Southwest style there there
was a different McDonald's one we got
two from there for some reason but that
one seemed a little bit more interesting
this one I think is just crispy chicken
so so it seems like McDonald's bring the
heat so dude McDonald's always brings
heed I have to give them props like all
damn just remember these these are
basically competing sounds flagship
salads same prices way too much meat in
this for me it's not good just get a
hamburger if that's what you're doing
with your life well next up is
chick-fil-a I don't I foresee bad things
from chick-fil-a after they lost that
shamba cough so to Popeyes I'm not I
feel oh they got creamy salsa okay give
me that creamy salsa dressing and it is
their own which that's new put it on
maybe huh so let's load it up but they
got so far McDonald's clear winner in
this battle on there and I mean I feel
like a complete fool saying this but I
feel like it's even worth going to
McDonald's for that's how my league
manager is calling me right now oh he's
up what did you guys tell Bobby the
complete mess good the chicken spicy
should we get a shot of this yeah yeah
let's reform beans the chicken is
delicious and spicy this is the
Southwest addressing as BOM and spicy
ins it's kind of a one for one with the
McDonald's okay it's really good that
dressings BOM dressing is good the
chicken is great wow wow wow wow
chick-fil-a salad generally going a lot
better than I think wide open
yeah this generally seems to be gone the
cheese like thick thick cuts of cheese
were if you look at like this [ __ ]
the bk1
they see the look at the BTR me look at
those thin little strips of cheese
that's yeah no [ __ ]
look at this cheese you see that that oh
wow fat strip of cheese baby
[Music]
so next this is interesting so next is
Domino's I'm a wild card here that's
bomb yeah that's mom I didn't
chick-fil-a take still of chick-fil-a
takes the lead all right is that cabbage
yeah I think so
truthfully definitely takes the lead
yeah Domino's has separated all the
ingredients I like that which is kind of
interesting as it keeps it fresh right
and that means they package the week ago
I don't like that means they packed it a
week ago that's rubbish it was such an
airport it was sealed yeah that's kind
of gross actually
that means they made it in a factory
like a month ago yeah it was like one of
these that's all I could you'll so
that's probably not great that's already
bad rating that's I'm into this that's a
crouton
so that one was chick-fil-a oh yeah all
I'm saying is the mic in the way
can you that's the opposite alright so
yeah this one I can't ever tell if this
camera is in focus or not so apologies
if but it always changes and I just
don't know I just let me erase them just
seriously yeah so here here's the
Domino's one this is looking pretty sad
this is the Delta Airlines solid it came
with a they got Mars Ettie to Mazzetti
oh my daddy
forget the Mars Eddie you know I put it
on its ranch though put it on cheers
dude that one an off the chain that
dressing is so good cheese like spicy
ranch bro get out of here yeah the
picture is actually way worse than how
it really looks right now chick-fil-a
picture looks so sad and weird yeah you
thought it was mushrooms on there yeah I
mean they it just looks strange I love
that there's a lot more stuff than just
a few lettuce pieces
it's all happening just cabbage Obrecht
chick-fil-a corn beans damn here's your
what do you say Delta Delta air okay so
this first of all some assembly required
this after dam labored also if we want
to talk about the environment why do we
need all this [ __ ] look at all this
extra packaging oh I see what you yeah
that's my boy this is not cute like what
do you think this is cute
no one cares about this no I think they
just really literally packaged it like
three months ago got to keep it edible
so I mean yeah this is one of the
saddest looking salads this is like
cafeteria at elementary schools no right
yes salad maybe even yeah can you hand
me the fork ela or I'll take another
four why not god bless well I mean I
pretty much know what this is gonna
taste
Gladys is pretty old man like I said
weak-ass [ __ ] well that's the care
that came with all different uh week
asked geez look at that [ __ ] ass cheese
flick I mean they're the only one that
in crew included croutons interesting
labia
what the [ __ ] yeah
ultimately I think this is actually the
worst salad I think there's even worse
than Arby's so who was that domino
domino damn worse than Arby's yeah damn
is it really you mean then this one I
mean at least that one was a side salad
and also someone tried to rape him oh my
god so that was kind of opponents here
try that
Oh Taco Bell I'm going in it looks like
we got those I think because I think
they gave us the wrong salad I feel like
the Taco Bell one is like a what's a
taco salad I mean it's a taco it's not
really a salad new
dance the resident vegetarian let them
decide it's still a salad painter what
are you putting on that yeah that's a
great question so that's salsa tostada
okay dump it on it because it's just old
no I am and on it but this looks like
this is chicken too so which is probably
good I want all the rest of it again I
wanted the ground beef I'm disappointed
so it's gonna keep better than the
ground beef Widow sitting in a fridge
for a day so currently Domino's is the
worst Domino's is by far the worst just
based on I think the age and the
assembly and everything but okay so good
I don't think this is fair to include
and this isn't a health dish it's not a
search by the way their chicken looks
like it was a taco Sally's not a solid
their chicken looks like it was frozen
dehydrated refrozen shipped to mars back
and then rehydrated again I mean I it's
alright I never had to talk about salsa
like this I'm frankly skeptical let me
try the checkout very spongy and thick
like it's lost the whole property of
what being meat is it's just horrid it's
just absolutely hard and there's so much
to I can't even get a bite without cheap
chicken in it was the worst this is the
worst
there's no beans rice and lettuce no
beans maybe a little bit to start it's
gotta be this is this is the worst
where's the Domino's worse than Domino
oh I felt like it wasn't even fair to
include oh it actually is a salad
it's a sec it's a salad but it's a bad
salad oh that's a salad that yeah that
is the worst Domino's like if I don't
here's a deal if my family was getting
booed up its tortilla strips if my
family was getting pizza Domino's I want
a salad I could eat that this is
inedible I would rather eat nothing than
that hmm damn yeah it's awful talk about
that the clear loser here hmm well we do
have I think one more right
scroll down Wendy Oh Wendy
you know this one I'm skeptical of it's
apple pecan it's like bro why are you
trying to get I'm trying to bring the
heat a little bit look we got like a
balm and burrata
like that candied walnuts I just want to
eat that here give me that no no hold on
respect the sanctity come on what God
working on it oh I don't like this
packaging all right we got some blue
cheese we got blue cheese from Wendy's
yeah blue cheese crumbles you mean you
mean because it's actually a rotting
yeah blue I'm gonna look blue when I'm
dead don't have oxygen hopefully there's
not a finger in there by the way this is
how this five dollars and 30 cents and
it's tiny
that's right money to eat that well you
don't like blue cheese crumble canal
okay well careful again but if I do it's
gonna be from a nice restaurant enough
yeah I mean they're kind of trying to
punch above their weight here might be a
fatal mistake from Wendy's
what kind of dress here we go simply
dressed Mars addy [ __ ] let me really ask
who and their goddamn line will go
through Wendy's in order a pecan apple
salad that is so insane to try to get a
gourmet ain't done no this one smells
pretty good
well they didn't make it then oh oh that
looks [ __ ] I know Wendy's a little
girl on it that looks so gross and you
just like grow a lot it's like a log I'm
gonna put a little bit on this side so
you can decide what kind of like a
barbecue sauce pomegranate is
pomegranate we got pomegranate blue
cheese Horrible's trihard Andy yeah
Wendy's has always been a try their
Twitter account is always [ __ ] will
try hard to make your food better next
time I mean you can't really go wrong
with candy become yeah those are always
good yes we always say asking them
really guessed it is you up like even
chewing in your ears I can't imagine how
do you listen to this would headphones
I'm loyal have fun I don't listen to it
at all to the show yeah I live it you
see I have a problem because I'm
avoiding the blue cheese you have to
taste you gotta taste it just the
rotting cheese okay I've got here I've
got a bite with everything on it oh and
a pecan yeah
taste the mold baby from Wendy that's
pretty funny you're gonna get sick from
our solid segment I know yeah yeah
I mean what can I say it's [ __ ] hard
it's just hard
I'm absolutely awful there's no way this
is on their menu this is so insane that
they would even think to add this yeah
I'm flabbergasted and my day is ruined
it doesn't look that bad
are you sure oh thank you dear clove
apple here to the [ __ ] burger is that
a fruit plate
look at this chunk of Apple go ahead you
look get a bite with everything in it
like I did okay
get one with the cheese the Apple
chicken the pecan
this to me is just a big like wow and
then on top of it you got pomegranate
vinaigrette to complicate the flavors
you or more it's just wrong who's
looking for those flavors in a
drive-thru yeah that's yeah yeah that
one's not good good that actually might
be the worst mmm
worse than the Domino's one that seems
hard to believe it's not
I would rather heat the Domino's than
that right I couldn't eat that I
couldn't eat it well if there was a gun
in my head and they say choose so so the
I think the Domino's is worth so the
notes is the Domino's the Taco Bell and
the Wendy's oh I forgot about Taco
Bell's doors talk about is that inedible
yeah yeah you really I will not be
actually I'd rather be executed and I
think the clear winner was chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a incredible and then second
was McDonald's yeah but chick-fil-a is
actually the clear winner here
damn yeah so if you're looking for a
good fast food salad chick-fil-a is God
I've gone you don't think that's the
worst one I mean look how you recoil to
talk about the worst I mean yeah thought
about looks the worst I'll give you that
so that's it we did it oh that's it
those are the salads if any if we missed
anybody sorry you know could we have
missed KFC maybe I think Ian did a
pretty thorough job yeah I think we got
all the big guys all the all the big
boys I personally learned a lot I think
that um what's their name chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a solid is something I would
go for that's the chick oh sorry this
you pointed to the wrong one you even
know that was the McDonald's yeah I
would order the chick flick well I'm not
going to chick flame buying salad let's
be honest but if you brought that to me
I would eat it yeah
and again it's like you're going to
McDonald's like you couldn't get a
burger and fries are you gonna get a
[ __ ] sad ass salad I mean ultimately
it's still strange to that option even
exists
because if you really care about getting
a salad go somewhere house true but
somehow I think you buy oh where can you
get a salad on a drive-thru right that's
true that's very true Leela finally
there you go there you have it folks
in summary Wendy's and Taco Bell and
Burger King and Arby's have truly
wha failed in a way that makes me want
to die and will ruin my week McDonald's
has elevated the game of fast-food
salads they are come and hittin it on
all cylinders but ultimately it was
chick-fil-a who prevailed rise to the
top with their spicy chicken slices
Santa fake creamy spicy ranch all the
way to Valhalla when it hits your mouth
it's a little spicy it's a little creamy
it's a little delicious and at the end
of the day you're gonna be saying damn I
wish I actually just had one of their
sandwiches because ultimately you're
going to fast food and you don't want to
anyway but if somebody brought it to you
or force you eat it you'd be like that
was pretty good I feel like that blue
cheese is not sitting well already I'm
telling you from the one bite yeah you
can't put blue cheese in a fast food all
right
Wendy's gets nothing little douche of
the Year award winner no it it may not
been him the worst technically a liberal
douche of the year Bobby's wallet he wha
he in every time he dropped poor wallet
let me look at this oh it's like a
little holder but it's like a little
that's a pretty cool I think it's what a
Ridge I think he's sponsored yeah I
won't know what their sponsor says use
co tiger belly who do you work for huh
dance pump the hell out of here use code
h3 even though I don't have a
sponsorship with them so poor Bobby he
sat down for one second to sing our
praises and he drops his wallet I want
an honest feedback from the audience
are these really watchable cuz I cannot
believe you always ask that and they
always say they like it you're the funny
one Amen sir though you're the they want
they like it look at this you look do I
need to prove this to you look at the
last one we did was chick chick fil-a
verse Popeyes h3 podcast okay let me
prove this to you this last one got and
I'm just gonna open this here really
good thumbnail in 600,000 views the
highlight Wow
Popeyes yes and I'll watch you right out
I don't give a [ __ ] Wow
yeah people like it okay Wow well I
better wrap this up cuz my feeling
windows coming closed I'm not kidding my
stomach kind of hurts dude I can't
believe you didn't say Wendy's was the
worst [ __ ] buckets of bleu cheese
tear dome from a try for the window dude
it's so gnarly
I got a bunch of stuff here leftover but
ultimately let's just talk about
actually I want to talk about D&D Dumb
and Dumber the makers of of Game of
Thrones who ruined the show they rushed
through the final season to go make a
Star Wars to make a Star Wars trilogy
they basically were handed the next Star
Wars trilogy that takes place after this
story arc that's wrapping up you know
and they got so much hate for the way
that they absolutely ruined Game of
Thrones worst writing possibly I've ever
seen on television I mean all these
beautiful story arcs that were marinated
over the course of many years were left
they just they were just rotting at
Wendy's rotting yeah
from from ripened to to rotting overripe
Wow they went nowhere and free folk is a
subreddit dedicated to hating on dumb
and dumber and Game of Thrones final
season and so I wanted to share some
these memes with you this is a really
high level so they were fired from Star
Wars the Maus sends his regards
obviously a reference to the red wedding
that's dumb and dumber they weren't
fired apparently they were fired well no
I thought they left because they're
beautiful according to free folk they
were fired but then it's they got picked
up for by Netflix for 300 million
dollars to them and that does make sense
they let me one show they're making good
writers rumor 300 million mm-hmm well
it's not confirmed but either way
according to that story they take with
the Star Wars because they're afraid
they won't have enough time to actually
do it right that's the official line but
with these things you know
well yeah you can't work for Disney and
Netflix yeah it's like they they already
butchered like everyone's favorite
series like they're you're not gonna
I don't know I feel like these guys
should never work again and I'll tell
you what I guarantee that whatever they
make for Netflix will be hot garbage
because they have proven that without
source material they are truly horrific
writers I mean really awful at the
developing characters and continuing dog
the arcs that george RR martin set out
they didn't even try and i'm i'd if they
won't if they make this show for
networks dude and they're paying them
300 million dollars you know it's gonna
be some crazy high budget high fantasy
[ __ ] they're gonna try to make some
their own version of Game of Thrones MMH
I like but I don't want these
knuckleheads doing it because they are
gonna ruin it if they try to write this
thing I just pray they hire some good
writers if these guys if these guys
attempt to write it it's gonna be awful
terrible thoughts ela I feel like in the
beginning maybe they were good right
because they when they translated to
move the books into the show so first if
you watch beginning first season it's a
completely different show the last one
it was the pacing was incredible so I
think maybe they're good at that part
well I don't know people well clearly I
mean Jordan RR martin was involved in
the early seasons as a producer and a
consultant and as George left the show
and they ran out of source material it
just turned into like a goddamn like
Jackie Chan movie and I actually that's
a disservice to Jackie Chan more like a
jean Vlad Claude a movie you know what I
mean
it was just all there was nothing value
Jon Vlad clad am
next vlog maybe John Vlad its
jean-claude van clock what are you uh
jean-claude mega fan jean-claude van
damme Jean flawed goddamn John Claude
Van Damme Jean Claude Claude Van Damme
jean-claude Clyde am can that guy change
his [ __ ] name you're four names like
hyphenated together idiot anyway bum bum
but you say what is racist is it its
Bamba Claude racist
I don't know when you even know her when
you find out nd yeah what it ran up
realizing D and E are at a star wars
realizing the game of thrones was ruined
for nothing I thought it was gonna be
Netflix hired them for 300 million but
that's true also when you realize the
game of thrones got rushed out for
nothing people say I look like this
image and I happen to agree it's Pablo
Escobar when your character art got
rushed because the writers wanted to do
a film series which they ended up not
doing off to work tomorrow with the
knowledge we won't have to suffer i D&D
Star Wars trilogy that's good I like
that like like like like like that David
and whatever exited a deal with Lucas
Films to produce a new Star Wars trilogy
delicious finally some good [ __ ]
content I don't get that one dad you've
never seen that Gordon Ramsay mean
before well if you're not familiar with
that then it's not gonna make sense to
you so go ahead and explain it to me
damn it
normally it says finally some good
[ __ ] food huh yeah because the
subreddit was stale but because this
happened now oh I see okay
I see I see I see
okay that makes it free folk carrying
that Netflix hired DMD fruitful carrying
Disney fired dandy yeah well kind of
stupid kind of stupid idea well done on
that one Zach fold that one up from the
security well I certainly look forward
to seeing how they ruin there's no way
these guys have only made one show and
I'm just telling you this how'd you get
a 300 million dollar deal they don't
even have credentials I mean they make
Game of Thrones but good by the grace of
Georgia our Martin do they walk those
guys literally made the I think the
writing of that last season was just I
mean there was none there was none I
agree I feel like there is some credit
in the beginning yeah but yeah the last
season was just no sane I mean the first
season was just so amazing it was just
so well done with Eddard and the
development of all the character is an
introduction I mean it was just it was
just so well done well let's see what
they got three hundred million dollars
Netflix I have a feeling you're gonna
big Lee regret that and finally we've
got popular streamer a shroud another
huge twitch streamer has jumped the
sinking ship of twitch and is going over
to mixer yes I said sinking ship twitch
is totally screwed shroud has a twitch
following of seven million and in 2019
he had a record high hours watched a
total of fifteen million in February and
currently already has around 580
thousand 508 sir you say his name shrewd
like the wait because I don't know well
I mean I may have met before I've seen
his name before I've just seen people
say shroud so you want to watch his
announcement video yeah
these guys are good at making
announcement videos to get a vehicle
doing [ __ ] I really wonder what my busy
busy getting but shrouded in ninja are
like the two biggest names on Twitch so
it's got to be a heavy blow man
so sick
yeah that's the gag No
hey Mike yeah what should do you in I
make a move and he misses you
oh hi Benji bunny good laps
I like it
so
they're certainly trying man mixer
making a good effort out there yeah you
know it's which immediately unpardonable
that's their petty little [ __ ] I
hate twitch they but every time they say
that it was a mistake right so why does
it keep happening because they're
[ __ ] petty little [ __ ] as I
said there's nothing wrong with sucking
[ __ ] by the way because I say Cox I cook
a lot
I think sucking [ __ ] awesome and I love
every time I get a [ __ ] I think is
the best okay I think I think on the
planet I mean just to be clear cuz I by
myself saying I'm like that's not derive
mean that's not really derogatory so
it's a good thing that Twitter
[ __ ] I will be I mean if somebody
sucking my [ __ ] they're my favorite
person on the planet at that moment so
they're not [ __ ] I take that back
what are they they're douches douches
isn't necessarily bad easy say vagina or
yeah and that's good form and that's
good so they're scum see that seems too
vulgar
too serious anal fissures mmm anal
fissure I like that that's pretty
graphic how do you get an anal fissure
you get [ __ ] in the ass too many times
you get blocked too many times
improper well that you know figures when
your large intestine falls out your ass
no that's not that's a pro oh so what's
the figure it's a cut on your [ __ ]
why is it called a fissure dramatic are
you sure has that happened to you Zach
no no no why do you know what a no
closure is I don't know I just hear it
throughout the years
yeah sure is a small tear in the thin
moist tissue that lines the anti-love
moist so there you go okay anal fissures
that's hard enlarged stools during a
bowel movement so how are you
probably you wouldn't know if you had a
exact you've had an anal fissure never
no no you know what they do for an
occasion you know what they do you go in
surgery with your legs up in the air who
don't know it's had an anal feature I'm
not so why do you know about the
procedure I know someone that had this
surgery okay
who I'm not gonna say okay so but you
you're close to this so they you put
your you put your legs in the air and
then what they literally cut around your
[ __ ] and flip it so they give you
like a new house that sounds wrong ever
heard bro they give you a new it's like
an inside out [ __ ] I could do that so
I got a facelift it's like the hassle
version that's fake I'm dead hey flips
your [ __ ] they flip with bigger
[ __ ] are you gonna do I'm gonna flip
your [ __ ] yeah yeah you know your
[ __ ] and balls are in the air and they
give you a new [ __ ] do they cover
your genitals or they just out I don't
know I guess that's the fear like the
doctor and when you were in the office
getting that procedure done did they
cover your genital I have never had any
I would admit if I hadn't you would I
believe Ian have you had no future
you're staying quiet not that I'm aware
does it hurt when you poop nope so far
so good
I never poop I only pee have you ever
had hemorrhoids
go ahead Ian answer the question oh
you're talking to me well I guess
everyone I thought that was a question -
Ethan - oh I've never had hemorrhoids
do you know I have my [ __ ] Bree I'm
trying to read about the surgery yeah
you trying to verify that [ __ ] Ian's
accent so it's on Wikipedia so what they
do is flip your [ __ ] yes I stared
that usually comes from passing large
all hard stools right mmm you turning me
honey look okay we carried the Metamucil
anyway a shroud joined mixer
and I did wait for Allah to I don't know
sacks flippin [ __ ] and I got all
excited it's fascinating it is fun it is
fascinating shroud is on mixer
he immediately lost his partnership
twitch stripped him of his verified
partner badge and his channel stops
showing up on the site search how about
that a spokesman for twitch told verge
that he disappeared from the search as a
result of a bug I like that they
confirmed that it happened but there say
I was a bug let's not forget how when
they dropped me out of their partner
program when I went back to YouTube that
they made me sign up again to get paid
and I told him the [ __ ] yeah idiots
those guys really not a burner but they
said it was because of a bug yes I mean
I just went to twitch and type shroud
and he's still not showing on well so
Bob it's a bug I think well you know in
theory they're just trying to make him
disappear because I don't want anyone
going over to mixer doctor disrespect
has a different take on the old mixer
thing and if I'm gonna be honest with
you I sense a little bitterness in the
docs response because he has been
shrouded in controversy that includes
filming people in the bathroom and
cheating on his wife and I think that
mixer possible perhaps would have come
to him with a juicy offer but that he
was passed over because of his
controversies and I think that easy but
I would never move the mixer trust me
it's stupid right now they probably have
maybe a total forty to fifty thousand
concurrent viewers across the entire
platform right now currently on twitch
right now currently across the entire
platform concurrent 1.5 million
concurrent view well I think
competitions great they're gonna have to
make better terms for everybody once a
mixer keeps siphoning off people guess
what doctor you're probably going to get
better terms from twitch to attract
people to stream their they twitch had
out total monopoly on streaming so
always gettin right with you ya know
that blues right though there was a
little a little bit of bitterness that's
voice there there's more so you tell me
you step into my face and say yeah
they're making big moves no they're not
right like I have double the amount of
viewers that ninja has right now and I'm
still in my intro right reality check
those moves they're not doing anything
for the platform you can't pay for a
community you can't buy viewership it's
right here did the twitch community it's
built on video games it's built on
communities
so get your flappy gums I'm sick and
tired of seeing it I'm sick of hearing
about it
play it [ __ ] play goddamn private I
know he's disagreeing with you but he's
the best he's so [ __ ] funny sorry
yeah who said are you thinking well it's
interesting to see I think what's gonna
happen with everyone I like the
competition twitch yeah I mean look
twitch is suck stay as a platform are
complacent they have a monopoly and they
suck as a their policy suck they're
bitter they have Amazon money they're
not often enough yeah it's run by like a
20 year old but a bunch of 20 year olds
and you know people anyone who's
watching this who from twitch I mean I
all the people I worked with from twitch
are super nice great people this is the
higher up kind of thing I think great I
think it's great for them I'm happy for
them and I'd love to see where mixer
goes and I think competition's awesome
that's what I think you know back in the
day there was a point where YouTube was
concerned that what was that one
platform that went under that was giving
everyone crazy lucrative deals no it was
something that gave exclusive access for
like a week on their platform
totally blanking but yeah they were
giving out these insane millions of
dollars to creators just supposed to
content they're exclusively for a week
before and actually one had a business
from handing out too much money but
YouTube was getting so worried about
this potential competition that they
were offering elevated CPMs to creators
they were giving huge packages to people
to stay on their platform and not sign
up with this so I'm saying these
companies have a lot to lose they're
making hands over fist shitloads of
money and we only have to gain from
increased competition better terms
better conditions bigger piece of the
pie you know what I'm saying choice is
good that's what the free market is all
about honestly yeah right Dan honestly
right do you hurt me well that's it you
want to watch them how long we've been
going far you've been going for many
hours to the minute we've got to fill
the dr. Phil cz and cheese burrito
regulars yeah I'll save this for next
week or on Friday I mean right are you
with that being said guys it's a
beautiful Tuesday oh and also we don't
find this what happens in the surgery
yeah that whole inverted anus is
questionable Zak you got it you know
what Zach here's what I want from you on
Friday I want you to put together a
report on anal fissure procedure I want
the facts because that sounds totally
wild and I want to know that that's
actually the thing
there are oh go ahead that's it okay
you've got an assignment but like
there's YouTube videos what else okay
you know what you're you're in college
in you put together a report on you no
no no I don't want you involved because
you're gonna muddy the waters and I mean
that not water
yeah muddy than [ __ ] yes okay but Ian
well-marked into this you will put
together a partial report that's your
job now as a salaried employee you are
for the show on what how do we fix anal
fissure what do we do as a doctor to fix
that address that issue I can I go nope
Zach you go to school you focus
understand
I have to give testimony of what exactly
I just found a little bit of detail and
I don't think zach is right
there's no way what do you mean here
I'll let you read it because I have
trouble reading this you sending it to
me yeah here we go the procedure entails
four steps gently whoa this is graphic
gently dilate the anus with special
retractors say that lis that means
you're putting in like you're putting a
pearl spreaders yes right now that
[ __ ] damn clean out the fissure with
a cure to curettage to stimulate healing
so you're cleaning the wound cauterized
the wound with electricity to seal the
wound injecting some kind of steroid
into the figure to promote healing so at
what point do you cut the anus and flip
it all all I know is the person that got
it done their aim is you go back to them
and ask them more about that okay why
would you cut the anus and flip it
because I think I think it depends on
the severity of it but the fissures in
the intestine well it's kind of on the
medium ground of the [ __ ] is this
person close to you is this some of you
yes okay so ask them for more details on
this procedure okay and Ian if you and
your research can find any procedure in
which the anus is flipped I'd like to
hear about it
all right I'm on it hmm sounds kind of
sexy gently dilate the anus with special
retractors clean out the fissure and I
from the person that told me this I do
know the pain after the surgery is
excruciating well you know it too much
about this person is in your family your
immediate family I'm not making anything
yes yes it's definitely someone in your
immediate family it's Zack I would come
clean there's I'd have no problem with
saying I have authorized the wound Exe
writes into the Fisher
damn now that the procedure they had
done was like 15 years ago so maybe it's
different now it's different
well cutting of the anus and flipping it
sounds like you need some new technology
that's high level all I know is the pain
after firm described is the worst pain
you will ever feel in your life it's the
most pain I've ever felt
I mean you will ever feel I never had it
alright we're wrapping it up hit me with
that music alright we're done the music
well guys that's another episode of pure
entertainment education drama and
everything in between we've learned a
lot we've learned a lot we've come far
we've got a table of salads here and a
queasy stomach thanks to the blue cheese
from Wendy's boo wins douche bag of the
century award for making us salad at a
drive-thru restaurant with blue cheese
well how psycho do you get and I thank
you all for watching this H fruit
podcast it's been a joy a privilege and
the privilege of my life I don't know
what I just said to entertain you
because I was born to entertain it's my
calling and purpose and I come before
you as your humble servant to make to
give meaning to your life and purpose
and frankly speaking I am I am the new
Jesus yeah and the spirit of Kayne I am
Jesus Christ who doesn't believe in
Christian values and regularly
masturbates and what's on Christ like I
drink I don't use drugs that much
anymore but I have I have what's on
Christ I'm just saying what is on Christ
like that I do then what it was what me
gluttony big time that's a big one thank
you and that is a big one literally
sloth sloth well I need a wrathful
sometimes a lot of pride yes what are
they all the sins I think you might tick
them all
well most isn't that less well not that
much oh I am married happily what who
are you guys to judge me let's do this
you can judge unless lest you be judged
you little [ __ ] how dare you judge me
your Lord I'm just kidding
I'm just a fat [ __ ] feeding window
even I apparently killed Jesus according
to Trisha - so that's not that's
literally not christ-like of me and what
else is there to say you guys anyone
else got anything
I saw people were saying that you get
angry at me at the end of the show Dan
do you think that that's a fair
assessment
did you see that comment no suppose the
people who someone was wondering why Dan
gets so angry at Ethan at the end of the
show it's not anger its frustration why
are you frustrated because I'm try and
elegantly end the show and and no matter
how hard I try it's just it doesn't even
matter does anyone like that song no
[Music]
Zach likes that song but in the end it
doesn't even matter
we just got claimed should I cut us out
yes I mean Danny I mean it's up to you
man what's the right everybody
spare me please yeah
[Music]